who's the winner that's the big question
at this agricultural show in Northern
Ireland the jury has a hard time
deciding and so do northern islands
30,000 farmers who are struggling with
an even bigger question whether or not
to stay in the EU farm alan Wilson is
especially concerned about the subsidies
specifically the single farm payment
that he currently receives directly from
Brussels the ones are saying leave
they're saying that we'll be able to
maybe improve where's the other one for
sale at the campus some farming families
in Northern Ireland us split down the
middle over the EU referendum but not
the Wilsons the father of the family
says there's no doubt that the industry
relies heavily on subsidies to survive I
don't believe that the subsidies would
be as as good if we were defending just
on on Breton because I don't think
Britain have the same they don't have
the same emphasis informant as was a lot
of the country to have the border to the
Republic of Ireland currently open is
another concern Irish farmer petty
sherry says a brexit would spell an end
to the single market since the English
makeup eighty-five percent of the UK's
population he feels the outcome of the
referendum isn't really in Northern
Ireland's hands they don't understand
what life is along the border here is
like you know in London and that they're
you know they're far away from what's
happening up here you know they don't
have to worry about Scott gun they don't
have to worry but Wales knew it they
don't have an international border in
England so they don't you know where as
in northern air they do you have an
international border other farmers on
the other hand are willing to accept
custom controls if that's what it takes
to cut back on regulations and
interference from Brussels I believe we
would be
better off out of Europe I would be in
favor of great because i'm not in favor
of people i haven't voted for telling me
what to do is too many too much red tip
since the EU was formed far too much red
tip the question of a brexit has proven
highly divisive alan Wilson just hopes
that the outcome of the vote won't mean
troubled waters ahead for northern
islands farmers